the bafta goes to
[Music]
jared harris chernobyl sky original
chernobyl was the night's big bafta
winner
and from its leading man a confession he
looked at me and he said um
jared i hope you don't mind me telling
you this but you weren't our first
choice
daniel day-lewis but he retired from
acting
overall it was a strange socially
distanced ceremony
filmed as live to avoid any major
technical gremlins if you're a fan of
video conferencing technology and
awkward pauses as people leave their
comfort orbits
you're about to hit pay dirt some
winners like romish ranganathan clearly
putting a little more effort into their
staging than others
the main takeaway well virtual
ceremonies can feel a little flat
wow it's been a while since i've played
to a place this empty
but the pandemic restrictions providing
no shortage of punch lines
the moment there's a vaccine norton will
be parachuted straight back
in there were valiant attempts to bring
the glamour
stephen graham somehow managing to stick
to the dress code and
keep cool stephen are you dressed up you
got dressed up for the occasion is that
right
well of course
idris elba was humble in receiving the
night's special award
what i've been given as an opportunity
and what i've done has taken my
opportunity and handed it backwards
among the night's big winners 84 year
old glenda jackson with her critically
acclaimed return to tv
i'm absolutely stunned
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber bullets
sky news also won a bafta for its
compelling coverage of the hong kong
protests
this award was a real team effort it
belongs to the local fixers the
producers
the camera teams all those behind the
scenes while the best was made of these
strange times
[Music]
no doubt organizers will be keeping
everything crossed that normal service
can resume again
next year that was the over-produced
zoom call
that is this year's british academy
television awards
katie spencer sky news